okay hi everyone this is a continuation
of our design review about diffs
and
let's see
uh why do we want to start
should we review okay so how far did we
get last time what is our next topic uh
well we got uh through all the basic
Diffie mechanisms we talked some about
three-way diffs
okay but let's let's look at
um let's remind ourselves we had a
granularity level
Okay so
right we've been talking about generate
a few different so on we haven't
resolved that now
the symbolic aspects of this right
right
okay because it's only Glory or somebody
else can you please remind us where we
got to last time
uh Glory wasn't in the last meeting but
uh uh but it's actually the list of
unresolved issues if you just scroll
down a bit is is summarized in the in
that notebook
foreign
let's not start with multi-alignment I
don't think right well so there's the
the third argument that that was
something a point that's worth
discussing
um
this is this is what I'm talking about
this is what we have to resolve first
okay okay
so my suggestion is
exactly this
diff
should produce
a minimal viewer
am I making sense
because we all agree that diff on two
big files
you know we don't want you know the
thing you want to see is something which
is heuristically showing you the right
things
if you want to produce get something
programmatic from it you should be able
to do that but the default thing is that
it should heuristically show you the
right things which it's convenient to do
in a viewer Okay so we've talked about
two possibilities
that you know it produces just a neutral
blob and that it produces a viewer there
is a third possibility that it produces
a blob that can become a viewer
interactively all right I agree
I think the right way to do it as we
talked about last time apparently we
don't remember is something like the
output size limiter
right well yes I mean we we I we we do
remember this it's just that we don't
all necessarily agree and there's two
lines that's the number one thing we
need to do before we start talking about
multi-alignment or anything like that
that's the most basic operation of this
thing is I type diff and I have you know
file one and I have file two and I want
to see something what do I want to see
coming out of that okay so what I think
we want to get is something which is
you know
a an appropriate viewer so so what so so
I mean here's a question which is what
does
diff actually return now
I mean it it's it clearly formats as
something right now it doesn't return
any particular thing the thing it
returns depends on the kind of view that
is happening automatically
so it has some arbitrary head
correct that doesn't necessarily survive
reinterpretation so I think that's I
think that's wrong I think what we
should do here
this should be visibly a viewer with
framing
rather than some exotic thing like this
where we don't really know what it is
okay once you have a a thing with
framing you know if you want a
programmatic version of this output you
know you have to extract that as a
property
and possibly it can have a raft or
something well well I don't see why the
programmatic thing
I mean I would argue that that right
that that should be a diff object and
the diff object should format as a
viewer
but you know if if I do if I do
lowercase diff equals Capital diff
semicolon that lowercase diff should be
a computable object I agree so as a
reminder we have two things right now we
have in the current iteration we have a
thing called diff and a thing called
generate diff I know uh which I think is
wrong okay we went through that last
time
well I mean the the point being
uh uh you know you I mean you just said
that diff should create something from
which you can extract the object
um I mean I'm I'm just no I'm saying
this is what should happen diff should
turn into diff object different format
as a viewer
deaf object should have sub values that
extract various computable things from
it and diff objects itself should itself
be computable so for example
you know I don't know if you diff
objects it should do the right thing and
so on
I'm making sense
yeah well I mean diff objects are
computable right now
um
fine then I think we've got is sorry
sorry I was I was muted right I'm just
saying yes I mean I think
I mean I feel like I'm acting up a
little bit of translate as translator
here but right basically the the claim
Steven's claim is that
the you know basically the the
formatting things that are provided by
dip should be just become format values
of diff object
which are the default thing that you see
with an appropriate heuristic diff
object should display as the thing
you're likely to see
yes at least in in some cases right
right if if it's going to be complicated
then it then it will just say you know
just like we do with any of these things
right if it's too complicated we just
show The Blob
yep
so you know a case like this it would
probably format with this with framing
basically
so
I mean one of the things that I worry
about is uh you know with with anything
along these lines is what happens if you
end up with uh dozens or more of these
things on screen at a time
it calls to mind the the struggles that
we had with uh uh having a summary blob
for I think it was for polygon uh that
actually rendered a thumbnail of of the
authentic polygon and in doing so it
burned a a lot of confidence so we have
to make sure we don't do that here just
like the the output size limiter
obviously doesn't blow everything up by
actually rendering the whole whole
object
okay so here's here's a different uh
possible issue so we have the stiff
object and we have these different views
right the same
uh right the same diff object can can
right right now we take generate the
output of generative and then we give
these different views now give if we
have the one diff object how do we tell
it to
you know go a different uh you know
yes well okay so so I'm saying that this
object by default okay there might be an
option to diff that determines what the
default
kind of you know attempted diff object
formatting should be and I say attempted
because if it turns out
that you know
the thing kind of is giant it's not
going to show the whole thing is what
I'm saying so
yeah I don't know whether that's an
argument of death
or whether it's you know
a diff format Arrow whatever option
if you get what I'm saying so I I just
realized something which is kind of
fundamental to think about here
um
many diff viewers
uh allow you to to see context including
deep into things that aren't different
uh sometimes it's just there by default
sometimes you have to expand it uh so a
diff object doesn't
carry the original objects around with
it and if it did it would potentially be
very large except that it's just a point
to him
right so what
well look look listen listen if you say
death of two files and they differ only
in one character
the diff object is
okay you're saying that the current diff
object as you have it doesn't carry
those files in it exactly and it
shouldn't it it carries around a small
amount of context information but but it
that's potentially tiny compared to the
files as a whole I understand that I
understand but whatever it was that you
asked it to death Okay so
well what is your solution I mean
somewhere you've got to be able to get
that context so somewhere it's got to be
available as well
I mean
what I'm concerned about is that that
may suggest that a fully general purpose
diff viewer which could be different
from what we're talking about here but a
fully general purpose diff viewer might
not be the diff object it might be a
different thing okay I don't agree okay
it's the same it's the same thing as the
issue we've had in videos for example is
the video in line or not
right or is the video referenced
somewhere else
right so what if you're but what if
you're I I don't agree yeah well if
you're dipping two notebook objects
those are inherently ephemeral
I understand I understand so you have a
choice just like you do with videos you
have a choice you can burn more memory
and make sure that it's local or you can
say there's no such thing as a right I
mean right notebook objects are
inherently right they're things that
only exist in Ram right
you don't have to I can always get the
notebook object I can say notebook get
and I can get it as an expression
right it's the exact same thing as we
have with videos in fact that's a very
good model for this
see what I'm saying
you know if I do okay look look typical
thing right we all know this
we say actually I could do this with a
too big or I can do it with a data set
or whatever
um
it's a bad example because it isn't big
enough
oh come on
that'll happen at some point no come on
here we go
there's not a notebook store now
okay that's what I think we should do
something modeled on that idea
am I making sense
you're making sense
I think this is a good idea consequence
I I disagree yeah I don't think it's a
good idea at all I think it's just
confusing
and and will lead to notebooks that are
extremely bloated potentially
okay look most of the time you won't
choose to do this most of the time a
diff is for the purpose of you know let
me you know let's look at the scenarios
okay
let's say you're different pieces of the
human gene now okay and most of it is
out on disk you're not going to put the
human genome in your notebook at least
not today
okay yeah I wonder if the if the um
I'm sorry for the silly thought but I'm
just you know right now our you know
digital storage is you know we DNA is a
much better form of storage but you know
anyway maybe maybe the evolved you know
species of the future will have much
bigger genome sequences and then it will
work differently but anyway never mind
or already crabs and potatoes have
bigger ones than we do so who knows what
that means
um Okay so
what was I saying so so them you know
it's conceivable you have two genes or
something
you want to send somebody a notebook
even though these genes are somewhat big
you want to put them in the notebook you
don't want them to you know have some
random faster file somewhere on disk
that was on your local machine and they
didn't have it
yeah it's exact same story as with
things like data sets and videos it's
very unlikely it's very unusual that you
say burn this video into the notebook
but occasionally you do it because it's
more important to you to have
transportability than it for it to be
small well note that it won't be
transportable in any usefully computable
way the only way in which it would be
transportable is that you would be able
to use the viewer to see the same thing
no I I I well yes and no it depends the
actual diffs maybe what you want to
compute things with
see what I'm saying
and the actual you know you may want the
actual object right right but but uh but
and you'd be able to get that from the
diff object
I would think so oh I would assume that
if you score the whole thing can you
from the sum of the numbers get all of
the original numbers that went into that
sum that's very bizarre no no no so so
look why not well but you're saying you
want context if you want context you can
just run the diff in the two different
directions so so
you mean yes but not as a part of the
objects
right I mean right if if if you know if
I send Linus you know a diff uh of the
kernel
right and that's you know however many
hundreds of megabytes or gigabytes at
this point but the diff object itself is
going to be what like you know
possibly under under a kilobyte but
having the you know but that doesn't
change the fact that there are
operations that need both the original
and
uh and and so the reason that that works
is because you're referencing the
original and it's the generic Linux
kernel that everybody you know that's
out there on some URL
if he didn't have that you wouldn't be
able to do this
so as part of the viewer yes but not as
part of the object
right exactly come on look why no no
look look it's the exact same thing as
with videos and data sets and so on
right an example you just gave no it's
not no it's not wait wait wait wait the
correct reference
is a web reference I mean at that point
at that Stephen at that point why don't
you know if if somebody has the two
objects they can run the diff and
compute it themselves
I understand I understand so so then
what's the point of burning them into
the diff object
I don't just send it I can just send
them I don't know but I think it will be
useful particularly for these more
computational uses of diffs that aren't
fulfilling I don't think there's anybody
here who agrees with you
well I think most people are silent so
okay I'm pretty sure let me let me point
out let's not let's not address this any
further right go ahead
I just wanted to point out that the
current uh diff
functionality has an option that lets
you include the full Expressions if you
know what you're doing and you really
want that okay obviously if the
expression totally needs so large they
don't blow out the notebook file size
that's fine so I it's just an option it
won't be the default it's not what most
people will want right but that doesn't
change the fact that for you know my use
case
I would want to have a viewer where I
can give it just the diff object that
somebody sent to me and uh you know a
pointer to our common reference great
view great so which is why right but
you've been denying the need for this
separate viewer function no no no I
don't think we need it yeah I don't
think we need it so I think we need a
way okay come on let's think it through
I I'm I'm really sure I'm right here for
once what was a bad sign
um what's that
well yeah we've we've we've been there
okay
I'm really sure this is the correct way
to do it okay so what I'm suggesting is
you know you do the diff you get this
thing which is a viewer okay now you say
but I want to give somebody somebody
sends me a diff object okay
I want to re-merge that diff object
with
a you know with a new option to the diff
object
in other words you've given me
the diff object itself will come with a
base pointer so to speak
okay so I'm saying that let's I mean it
won't be called that right base pointer
or source source pointer Source
reference now by the way we've got a
bunch of great precedents for how this
works we don't have these people in this
meeting but resource objects are full of
these kinds of things
okay resource objects exactly have
different ways to point to stuff you
know we've got we've got very well
nicely developed technology for this
we've got you know persistent objects
and resource objects and so on they all
have this ability to either Point
locally to local objects to Cloud
objects to URLs Etc et cetera et cetera
Okay so
let me clarify a counter proposal here
uh it doesn't have to be you know uh
full viewer or nothing it can be
something in between
so the sort of thing that I'm putting
out on the table
is that
diff object can be a thing which
which formats displaying you know some
level of differencing
but
it's but what that formats into isn't
the full featured everything you might
want to do viewer
why
why why not but I don't why not because
the full featured everything you might
want to do viewer
you know can do things like uh uh well I
mean you know I can do things like read
The Source material without having to
turn it into the yeah but I mean that
means you you have a function look
there's a million ways to do that you
can do it by saying you've got a diff
object okay look look and and and also
and also at some point you know uh this
is a a bit on from where we want to
immediately discuss but at some point we
might want to talk about uh dealing with
uh you know having a viewer where you
can actually modify things where you
know you're dealing with a three-way
diff and you want to make decisions
about it I agree that's a mutable data
structure you know back you know that's
a more complicated thing we don't have
very many of those
let's talk through those issues okay
all right so I don't disagree there's no
reason you know we have a diff object
here
the deaf object has a UI that allows you
to access lots of aspects of the diff
object the diff object could carry along
a source reference through mechanisms
like this
and there might even be a way of you
know like the source reference could by
default be a reference just like it is
for a video
right or data set for example
an in-memory reference or an out-of-core
reference
and then one of the things in the UI
might be a thing that says Okay I want
to burn this reference into the notebook
here
I'm making sense
would you say it's going to be useless
but Lou already put it in
I think it's going to be useful in some
cases
okay I think most of the time it's not
going to be useful but sometimes it's
going to be really useful
you know even in the documentation about
how to use this it will be useful and we
want and we won't have a bunch of pink
boxes coming out because the source
material wasn't there
okay then
well in my proposal there there couldn't
be pink boxes because the
the The Limited viewer you would get
from default formatting would only rely
on yeah I know but I think that's wrong
so I mean I think you should be able to
get to more stuff from that and you know
we can handle that in a whole variety of
ways okay then I don't disagree
that having a function called diff view
or something that
has a bunch of you know second arguments
that are the type of viewer and has all
kinds of options and so on that seems
fine I mean it's like show it's like the
difference in plot and show
okay and and then this
those options that are provided here
could also be provided probably in the
original diff object causing the I'm
sorry in the original diff causing the
diff objects default display to follow
those options in some way
does that make sense
sorry I I I I missed I didn't understand
I I I lost I I lost it all right let's
go through it again okay so diff turns
into a diff object the diff object
displays in some default way that is
somewhat heuristic
okay the diff object has a UI that
allows you to specify different forms of
display
with me so far
okay the dip object also has a UI that
allows you to burn in by default it will
have pointers to Source objects the diff
object would allow you to burn in the
those Source object things if it turns
out that data isn't always right
okay
right well I I but yeah I mean I just
don't understand what sort of pointers
you're talking about when we're talking
about say General Expressions right
either the expression to memory point is
to memory that that just it's just the
exact same thing that is happening here
in this data set it says data not in
Notebook no but but but that's but it's
still but it's still an end of 260 right
it's not in the note you're worried only
about notebook size I'm also worried
about you know the object itself n of
260 still has a million okay so in
another case then is its file of
you know or something or you know the
directory of the whole Linux sources
that's the other possibility for you
right and so burning that into the
notebook is kind of a bad idea because
it's going to read it all in and it's
going to put that in literal form as
characters in The Notebook
but by default the pointer will be to an
external file or an external URL
that's that's I mean that's
I I I mean you're still not addressing
the point that I'm making which is I I I
I'm worried about the full form of diff
object
right I understand I understand if you
burnt in the complete Linux sources
there you would blow yourself up uh well
but I you know I'm not talking about the
complete Linux sources I'm talking about
right this good this can you know diff
two lists and two strings yep and you
know
um I you know I I either the you know
you're talking about a situation where
either the uh you know
okay
that doesn't round trip or
okay okay look
look
and you need to deal with the fact that
there are things that we produce as
output that cannot be given as input
that's what we've tried to patch over
with things like this
if I took this and I just put it in
another notebook for example it would
not work as input same thing if I hadn't
done this right same thing with many
other structures that we have
okay you're commenting that the same
thing will happen here I agree
no that's that's not what I'm commenting
I'm I'm commenting that I believe the
full form of
of of you know if I you know if I if I
do diff of range of a thousand and range
of you know 1 000 of two comma yeah
that the full form of the diff object
should not have two one million element
uh listen them okay all right okay
because because it's an efficiency hack
you want to make sure that that for
example okay so in this case right
okay reasonable display there okay
reasonable display
now you what's the input form of this
thing
um you you want generate diff to look at
the diff object
Utah is concerned about the diff objects
just silly the fact that there are two
functions there it's just Stephen
Stephen hey hey we're having a design
discussion okay okay I'm just getting
frustrated because we are having I think
uh
so Ty cares about the input form of this
okay thank you I I don't want to see two
million additional elements I agree with
you I agree 100 right so that has
nothing to do with the store and
notebook object and it's stored in
Notebook uh right this is truly a kernel
evaluation question
the diff object the input form of the
diff object that's what I just did here
no yes oh yes there there yes right I'm
concerned about that thing that is what
I'm concerned about I agree with you
okay so here's what we need to do
right so this is what we're gonna have
it'll say changes here okay so one of
the things it might say
is you know left Source or whatever the
heck I don't know what you call it here
left you know
or before Source or something okay
before Source Arrow URL blah blah blah
but there's no URL here don't don't give
me no no I'm talking about this I'm
talking about this this uh you know this
case right here okay
by default before Source should not be
in this Association okay so I think I
agree with you I think this case we're
out of luck there's no way to get
there's no way to record something once
you've done the diff once you've done
the diff You've Lost That input there
you've lost that if you wanted to save
it give put it in a variable
okay I agree with you on the other hand
if that had said video or something or
you know Chicago or or if I mean the
case I'm interested about in would be
you know if this were uh a git object
and right I would want it to record the
the get repo and and the shaw
yeah and because then that's something I
can send to Jose across the hall and he
can do something with it without copying
all the kernel sources exactly so I'm
saying when there is a you know this is
again
the death object in the case where it is
just an in-memory expression before
source is going to say missing
unavailable or something okay
but if it is if it can have something
that's a meaningful pointer it puts it
in there okay
and and I think the UI should allow the
possibility of burning it in into the
before source as an explicit expression
I don't know how that's exactly and you
know and if you do the wrong thing there
then that's stupid and whatever but
sometimes it's going to be useful yep
and we we've always we've long allowed
you to shoot yourself into foot if
that's what you really want to do indeed
right okay so now
all right so let's go back here
to the question of and so by the way
this this deals with the question of
whether the
diff viewer can have access to context
now by the way
okay so one of the issues here
is
you want to be able to give something
a a reference to this expression without
it being in
the serialized form of the diff object
see what I'm saying
well don't want it I don't want it but I
don't know you guys want it you want to
be able to show context
right so in other words if this is range
of a million right right I mean the
problem is the diff object itself
in you know for us in memory you know it
doesn't matter range of a million it's
like who cares it's just a it's just a
pointer in memory the problem is that
when you serialize it you will see range
of a million and there as a as a as an
explicit list of a Million numbers and
you don't want that yeah right okay so
the the problem is that there is
something which has a an expression
level reference but you don't want it in
the serialized form
and that's what you were doing with the
generate diff object etc etc which I
think is the wrong way around
okay now what you're also adding
is the idea that I might want to in The
Notebook
view this diff relative to this
expression which is in memory which is
big
which I don't want to be part of the
serialized form but I still want to view
things relative to that
does that make sense
yeah
so one of the questions here is
I mean
you know but yet you think that it is a
better thing to be able to copy the diff
object
stick in an email
which I don't disagree is a nice thing
as opposed to having to say export or
having something well here's a question
here's a question
if this stiff object were essentially a
graphic not not an actual graphic but
something like a graphic and I copy it
and I paste it somewhere else
clearly by clipboard magic it's going to
do the right thing
we hope yes right so in other words
imagine
that I mean in memory there's no problem
with this stiff object referencing range
of a million doesn't matter it's fine
with that the problem is if you try to
serialize it and copy paste it into an
email it'll blow things up
does that make sense
you're right
I mean I suppose theoretically we could
replace it with like a weak uh
perhaps we could do something like a
weak cash
and and a pointer you know a key to a
week we cash table so it'll be small in
serialized form but still as long as
you're in the same session
that's an interesting idea
well or alternatively what it really
what you're saying there and it's a
mechanism we don't have so far as I know
if you said a local object for example
that's remember that no but maybe that
is no no that's on that's on the file
system
what you're saying is
you know that it is a thing which we
don't have this mechanism really do we
like we an internal object
where that internal object
is resolvable
surely we have this mechanism somehow
well that internal object just
you say make something into an internal
object fine it hands you back a uuid
okay
and then we we have this we have the
expression objects we have something
like this okay it hands you back a uuid
you stick that uuid in your expression
were you to need to resolve the thing it
would
you know it would say okay do I have the
studio ideas it's still valid am I in
the you know am I in the right session
if no then sorry you know can't find it
if yes here you are
that make sense
so and and my claim has been that's
potentially useful to
preserve the viewing operation but other
operations
um uh I mean you know one of the big
operations that you're going to want for
this Beyond viewing it is of course
applying it and in applying it the the
source information doesn't uh doesn't
matter I mean you actually don't want
the source information because so so
then ignore the uuid
I mean if the uuid is before uuid you
know if it's a thing called you know
Source uuid or something like source
source pointer whatever it is and that
pointer is to a uuid thing and that uuid
no longer resolves well then you're
cooked if the um
if you don't care about the uuid well
just don't look at it
but it's not taking up a lot of memory
yeah
and and so you know that means the the
the default view
uh
will will be uh you know something that
should be
uh recreatable from the diff object
minus the source information so that's
you know I refer to this limited diff
view as opposed to the full diff view
full diff view requires the source
material
but the limited diff view doesn't it can
just work with the information actually
and the zip object and uh and obviously
or the the before source is something
that needs to be resettable because uh
one of the most common operations
in in the git workflow is to take the
same patch set and apply it to different
Shahs yeah and and see what results okay
so the question then is given a diff
object what is it sub value
do you does it sub-value do we actually
treat a diff object do we actually not
make it a dip object but call it a diff
function
and have the diff function be something
that actually is you know applies so by
the way you can see what's implemented
today uh Lou right it just takes
properties and you can see that is that
right
yes yeah so just you know type in
bracket properties bracket after that
output
or percent whatever yeah
right that's its current sub-valued
behavior yes yes that's what's happening
and so now it has a separate function
that's called apply diff is that correct
correct
it's not obvious to me what's right I
mean I think this is not obviously wrong
I think it's very I mean I just don't
know how common
I mean if you had a diff function how
cool would it be
or do you not care
sorry how cool would what be to have a
diff function well you just use as a sub
value you just apply it you know you
want to say let's say for example apply
this diff across 100 files you know
being able to just say diff object diff
function slash at
you know all the files or file you know
like for example oh oh oh oh using the
diff object as a head against the thing
you want to apply it to I yes surely
there would be concern about overlap
with uh uh with the properties value no
no no no no I'm saying I'm asking you
the question if there was a thing
magically called diff function
okay forget about the conflict with
properties okay if there was a diff
function how excited would you be about
that is it is it something where that
would look really nice or is it
something where who cares because
there's so much other equipment that has
to be around when you apply the diff
I'm leaning towards the ladder but it's
possible I'm missing something
okay
all right so I mean the issue is
Okay so
right now
there's a separate function apply diff
so you've got def which creates the diff
object apply diff which applies a diff
object right
and
perhaps you have diff View
that is some kind of
show like construct for diff objects
I mean I I you know I have to say my
slight preference is to have diff view
rather than some crazy thing with um uh
you know some uh you know sub value with
options and blah blah blah blah hey what
what do we do for
video if you want to change
so for image I guess we wrap it again in
image with new options that is correct
uh do we do the same thing with video or
something else I assume yes
okay but I mean with video there are
more complicated operations like video
recode and things sure yeah right so
again it's a more sophisticated
I'm guessing that some things we can
just wrap it
and I mean like like for example image
resize
is an operation not just a wrapper
so I'm saying I mean I think if you want
to change the exif date right you
certainly have it yeah uh it's just it's
it's always bug me a bit when you
on on an arbitrary object that you just
want to do some options surgery and and
maybe there are better patterns for
doing that than I'm aware of it it
always seems clunky when I try to do it
for what for the for the well for for
any object where you're preserving you
know the central object's Integrity
changes options
yes yes and graph is one where where it
does just have the outer wrapper okay so
as a very serious user of the graph
function okay I can say that most of the
time it works very nicely there are
Corner cases some of which frankly are
bugs and don't need to be broken but
they get take years to find because
people just don't really understand that
it is a bug as opposed to that it
couldn't be done and I'm sorry graph is
like image where you just wrap it and
graph okay yes yes and it works I mean I
use it every day it works very nicely
most of the time except that like Nick
who's here recently found some Corner
cases that are wrong okay
but
you know
I bet those have been seen before but
nobody knew they were bugs nobody was
pushy enough to say it's a bug
um but but in general it works nicely
um
and um so I think go ahead I mean the
sorry I was momentarily distracted but
you know sort of the one issue with with
sort of you know continually changing
options is right then there isn't an
easy way to say if
two guys are the same or maybe we
we'd have to think about like are these
two diff objects the same except for you
know viewing options I understand that's
complicated right I don't know again you
tell me
this is a subject important yeah I mean
this is you know like my example would
be that uh we don't at least as far as I
know we don't have a similar sort of
operation for manipulate
it's not something that people would use
that much if we did but on the rare
cases when you want to kind of how do
you do it oh you have to end up doing
some pattern matching surgery or
something oh yeah okay look I got a
suggestion so with diff objects and
comparisons you know
triple equals is probably not a good
thing to use with diff objects
right you know it's conceivable doubly
if if it's an important operation double
equals could work and ignore viewing
options
or alternatively hash
I'm not sure if hash should I don't
think hash should ignore viewing options
I think it's too structural but you
could have a property of diff object
that's called Char or hash or whatever
it is but right and and that way you
know in in the right yeah now that I'm
thinking through this a bit more I think
probably what you want to compare it's
not the diff object itself but if you
know some way to
uh for example you want to know if the
diff object is empty if it represents an
empty diff
right or you want to know if these two
objects are essential you know have the
same
changes right basically if they
represent the same operation
irrespective of you know Source data or
anything else because that's certainly
something that I some sometimes need to
do where it's like okay you know are are
these two branches basically making the
same set of changes and so then I create
two diffs and then I dip the diffs and
ignore the the stupid okay so look look
I think we're gonna probably need a diff
dif so to speak I mean a diff
given that they're all expressions or
I mean so for example the the
representation of an empty death
should be something very clean certainly
in the viewer it can be clean
but it should be easy to determine that
the thing is an empty diff uh see the
problem is that you might want to carry
along viewing options even for an empty
diff just like a show of an empty
graphic might want to carry viewing
options yeah
but
uh you know I don't think it's terrible
to imagine a little cluster of functions
you know diff equal and things like this
um I think that's better than hiding all
that stuff in weird options or weird
properties
okay well well that gives us the design
Direction then
um if if you're kind of signing off in
principle on functions like you know
diff equal diff empty you know that sort
of thing uh then we can we can start to
design around that and iterate yes yes
but I mean I think okay so let's review
again okay so I want to go back to some
of the other things which were
inhale okay so first thing is we need a
graphic design for the default diff
viewer okay and how it unfills itself
and
you know okay I want to come to another
issue yeah and unfortunately we'll need
probably a multiplicity of designs
because it will depend on what otherwise
you actually dipped yeah right so but it
needs to design you know a an overall
you know
uh sort of brand approach which I think
won't be the same as the as the output
size limiter it won't be it'll be a
different thing than we've had before
because I think these diffs like the one
you displaying in 261 there is you know
I think it wants a little bit of light
framing but not too much
I think you want it on white probably I
don't think you want to you know have
some weird thing with blue and all that
kind of thing it's going to be
complicated enough without doing that
and by the way just as a an aside one of
the things that's been brought up is
that the typical color experience which
I I think we want to use because you
know lots of people expect it to work
that way uh but the typical color
experience is not uh colorblind friendly
um and so it would be good to have a you
know colorblind friendly option
yep
wow I'm surprised nobody fixed that in
all these years well so uh we uh our uh
get our internal get hosting solution
has uh you know it uses green and red uh
by default but then you know there's a
personalized option that you can pick
you know which goes to that blue and
yellow I think it is okay so we can have
a theme type thing you know just like we
have plot theme we could imagine a diff
theme possibly
that we use as an option
to the diff viewer which which I mean my
claim is that most of those options like
diff theme let's say which I don't think
would be a stupid thing to have can be
both options to diff itself and options
to the rapper diff viewer to be applied
to the diff object
um now what I'm also interested in is
when when the diff object returns
you know some of these things like
removals some of them are just purely
lists of of things but some of them need
to structure themselves
did you see what I'm saying
uh uh I I I don't quite know where
you're going okay look look look look
if I say changes here
okay what the hell is that
so that is the changes element of the
association from the same time
so I can describe what all these numbers
mean no no I'm not interested in that
okay I am at some point but I mean the
point that I'm trying to make is there's
yet more structured stuff here
okay just like a diff object is a
structured thing I mean we could okay
the comparison sequence alignment
is something very on
you know if I just do sequence alignment
we made the decision in sequence
alignment which might or might not have
been correct
to say you know
okay that's a sort of incomprehensible
thing
okay it doesn't have structure it's just
you have to take it apart yourself
are making sense as opposed to something
that's a whole association with you know
because in wherever it was in this form
here right okay okay this is part of why
we've been having a bit of trouble
tracking because by structure you mean
at least in part you mean human
comprehensible structure
yes I I think I mean that I mean I mean
things where it is self-evidently easy
to go in and write code that does it
whereas here I mean I've done this many
times in sequence alignment you know of
writing something that for example right
puts these things on top of each other
and so on and so on and so on
I'm saying I mean so so in other words I
mean I might say something like I mean I
don't know what would I do here I would
say you know if it's of depth
to
you know stack it is there an easy way
to do that
if I say column of the whole thing it's
going to be well I mean okay so let's
say I say no it's not there's not really
an easy way to do it I have to say if
depth of hash greater than one column of
hash
otherwise
well that did the wrong thing
that's greater than two perhaps
okay something like that but that's kind
of messy
am I making sense
and um
so I mean there's a trade-off here of of
some things when it's just a
list of
you know
additions for example
okay so I I assume additions maybe it
isn't maybe that's complicated too
oops
I see well I don't know but what I would
have to do to get that but I mean is
that going to be a complicated you know
thing with a bunch of detail in it or is
it just going to be a list of additions
will be the pieces of changes that
represent additions so changes is giving
you all possible changes some of those
might be additions in this case there's
only one item in there that's not a
match and that's a change an edit okay
but so what I'm what I'm looking for is
some things here
will just be a list of things 50 51 or
something like that other things will
have and what I'm a bit concerned about
is the incoherence of oh we got one
structure for changes we've got another
structure of a conflicts we've got
another structure for this or is that
not a valid concern well so changes is
just a list of all of those things
together
right so what's each individual thing
what's the definition of matches
additions removals at its conflicts no
no I understand that but you're giving
this in the case of a list you're giving
it with part numbers correct what do you
do if it's a string for example then
it's string index position numbers
character counts okay do you know D is
that obvious does it show that
does it say the word character count no
the diff object however does say that
it's a diff object from strings
okay but but when you get the thing out
if all if you just look at a piece of it
you're going to lose the context that it
came from strings
other than that see this here okay I
consider this
a bit iffy maybe I mean this is a
decision we have to make right at this
point
these are structures so that structure
there is not the same as the sequence
alignment structure but it could be
making sense
I don't understand why that first since
there's one one by the way why does it
say one those are the starting positions
in each string of the following
substrates yes yes
okay but but look this thing could as
well be the sequence alignment output
right not nearly what's that nearly
um the one way in which it's not is the
illusions
that you see in out of 267. what about
this that's that's the sequence
alignment case yes but if these strings
were hundreds of characters long you'd
see illusions
that you don't get in sequence alignment
but not in changes you wouldn't yes you
would
no this this comes back to the point
that the diff object doesn't carry
around the entire Source objects in your
case it is because the source objects
are so small
that they're that that because what they
do carry around they do carry around the
context of the changes and contexts you
know covers a certain region of things
that didn't change if your expression is
small the context is going to cover the
entire expression but we probably need
an object that represents that
contextualized thing
it's kind of a sequence
it's a
it's a sequence context to something I
don't know what it is
okay but but any case let's so this is
another issue is exactly what are all
these things right okay here's a way to
think about it what's the workflow of
you extract changes and then you feed it
into another function what's that other
function
what kind of thing works with it if you
feed it to take and drop can you feed it
to replace part what does it what can
you do with it
fair question
blue so there's so there's yeah we're
thinking one can use the diff
uh so do are there examples of other
objects which can be whose properties
can be extracted and used I imagine
there are lots of array would be an
example I mean the the big thing that I
think we'd want to do here is to be able
to modify the diff object itself
to say you know this particular removal
Edition uh we just don't want it you
know remove it from the diff object wow
for example so I think that's another
function I think you need another
wrap-up function that does that cool you
know different places or something like
that well it but but what I'm getting at
is uh maybe and I say when I'm getting
at I hadn't actually gotten there yet so
sorry uh is that maybe if you start by
you know getting the changes you know
and and and and then kind of do your
magic on those and then can you convert
those that list of changes back to a
diff object
if that's the most sensible workflow
yeah I mean one one thing that came up
in the last meeting when Stephen
suggested that we just allow the output
of sequence alignment to be a thing that
you can feed to diff and that diff would
digest it
um I think that would probably cover
the case that you're talking about John
okay
I'm not 100 for sure but
but it's it's definitely the case that
there are you know it's not common but
uh there are cases where yes I
definitely do want to modify diff
objects in some way whether that's a
function that does those modifications
or whether I can you know kind of boil
it down to Raw data process the raw data
and then uh reintegrate it into a diff
object uh I mean those are the two
possible workflows I'm imagining
sorry I I've spaced out for a second
could you say that again right right
okay so uh I want to make a change to a
diff object I can imagine two ways of
doing it one as you say you know have
you know some kind of diff modifying
functions like diff replace or whatever
that's one possibility another
possibility would be to uh you know to
basically
uh just pull the raw data out of the
diff object process the raw data
directly and it which might be something
like this changes list or yeah and then
repackage it and then repackage it yes
yeah but okay so a modification of both
of those would be that you could just
say changes Arrow and then you know in
the diff diff modify or something
changes Arrow blah blah blah I mean this
reminds me a little bit like in
molecules and maybe Michael Jason who's
here and hasn't had a chance to say
anything you know however we have
molecule modify for example that's a
case where we're poking at a fairly
complicated structure and making changes
to it
correct
is atomic and that's the only way that
you should change it
yes sorry and that that and that's might
be sort of similar to this
that you have certain I mean in that
particular case you have certain
operations that you do with the molecule
I mean here
I'm a little bit suspicious of taking
apart into its stiff object pieces you
know modify it with generic code and put
it back together again so so I will say
that you know there is a version of that
workflow in the git world that I do and
many other people do all the time uh I I
literally do it on a daily basis uh
which is to say that uh I have made
changes locally to my source code uh and
I am going to package up those changes
into a commit uh now the most common
workflow is I just
add all the changes to the commit and
it's done everything I change goes into
the commit but there's also a very
common workflow where you say I don't
want every change that I made I want to
split this up in some way or I just want
something to not go in at all you know
maybe I have a bit of debugging code I
don't want to remove but I don't want to
commit it either or maybe I've made
changes which kind of logically makes
sense as two commits but I wrote them in
one go so I kind of now need to you know
add some pieces to commit one and some
pieces to commit to what what happens
when you do that what happens to your
local copy when you make one of those
commits does the local copy then
rearrange itself to be a diff relative
to the now committed code well so uh so
git has three areas that are relevant to
this uh it has the working directory uh
which a commit operation will never
touch uh the you know the working
directory is just I it that's where I'm
editing that's where my editor is
pointed to is the working directory okay
so then it has the the commit store uh
and obviously when a commit is finished
and done it goes into the commit store
um but then it has a third area uh
called confusingly the index or in order
to use a less generic term some people
have tried to rename it the staging area
and the staging area is basically where
it keeps track of the commit that you're
intending to create
and and it's by effectively moving you
know these diffs possibly in their
entirety or possibly a line at a time uh
into and out of the staging area that
you're declaring what the next commit
what the contents of the next commit are
going to be
and there are you know options to allow
you right so you can compare the index
to the working tree you can compare the
index to the commit store you can add
compare the commit store directly to the
working tree Etc
so we should learn from that but but I
always want to raise it and and I should
say you know it's it's not the easiest
thing you know when you have people who
don't have a lot of experience with this
kind of walking into it this this notion
of kind of three different areas holding
your code it's a bit confusing it's the
kind of thing where you know you have to
learn the tool and really kind of yeah
okay but but one case that you
have raised
is
modifying the sources
you know that is going clicking through
whatever and saying do this do that
Etc
the process of moving things into or out
of the staging area yes okay so
let's say in the diff viewer okay so I
just want to think this through for a
second whether we can do something
without it being mutable
okay
and what our analogies to that are
well and John in your case you're not
actually changing the diff right you're
selecting pieces of the diff
for the staging area that's correct and
you're not selecting other pieces I mean
in in essence I'm in a way I'm creating
a second diff from the first dish okay
so the mail I make a suggestion so so
let's say you have this stiff object
which is displaying in the diff as a
diff viewer okay
then you go in you point your you start
editing in the notebook you click okay
why not copy down
and why not allow you to actually edit
you know in the diff viewer
and
when if you hit shift enter
the thing you get
is an edited diff object
okay I'm not I'm not I'm not opposed to
that uh except it's it's going to be a
bit of a high wire act implement but I
understand but I mean not opposed to it
but but I'm yeah but I'm also rooting
for a programmatic way to do the same
thing absolutely I agree with you okay
but in the Clickety Clickety click I
want to take this one don't take that
one and so on but programmatically
you might say
you know I want to take all these diffs
that have this feature but you know the
things which are not going to be easy to
do programmatically the things that are
not going to be easy to do by hand
um
you're saying
you know so
programmatically I've got a list of
changes
right each change it's not really
labeled there's just a list of them I
want to take changes three seven and
eighteen yeah
okay
so I agree with you that
some kind of
you know it's basically a diff to a diff
it's basically a an explicit as opposed
okay the thing okay so so one way to
think about it would be
that you write a diff object by giving
a minimalized Association so in other
words if all I do is to say diff object
of the association changes Arrow
5 goes to whatever it is whatever back
it is okay
and then the canonical then the diff
object Puffs itself out by
canonicalizing in some way or maybe
doesn't maybe maybe basically what I'm
looking for is a diff apply of that diff
object
to your death
I don't know that's the right way to
think about it but that will be one
possibility I don't know if it is or not
either right but I mean then the the
other possibility is that there is a
diff change diff modify function that
takes just like molecule modify takes
certain kinds of you know things you
might want to do to a diff so to speak
mm-hmm
and you know maybe there's a definite
list of them maybe there's an obvious
Syntax for it I don't know but that
that's the other possibility so in other
words there's diff apply which is taken
take an expression and apply a diff to
it and there's
you know
some kind of diff change that changes
the diff itself
the fact that those have to be different
is disappointing
yeah I mean here's another argument
here's another possibility by the way
would it be helpful I I kind of came up
with I think a pragmatic example if it
would be helpful in terms of how to
think about this go ahead so imagine
you're doing a notebook diff and imagine
in your copy of the notebook you maybe
you make notes to yourself and in those
notes you you add a private cell tag and
so now you want to send those changes to
uh someone else but you don't want to
send the private stuff so you basically
say look for any additions of cells with
a private cell tag and remove those from
the diff object
yep
yeah it's a good example
so I mean to make that as easy as
possible you know it will be a delete
cases or delete key or something like
that yeah delete cases of this thing and
if that's nice and easy then we're in
good shape but the thing that concerns
me is that thing at line 267 there the
thing you know things like this are
comparatively hard to deal with as I
showed down here right sure yeah
and so that's really the question is how
how straightforward can these things be
so that you can just run delete cases
which is again this question I was
asking before given the object that
comes out what are the functions most
likely to be applied to it
yeah and my example frankly was one of
the simpler cases you kind of design
that way so the example would be
comprehensible but was one of the
simpler cases one can imagine it's you
know it's only looking for additions and
basically if you don't like the addition
you just throw it out or or you it you
know it might be in the middle of three
or four other editions so you might have
to surgically
remove it from a sequence of cells right
yeah so I can imagine in the case of
notebook diffs
that
the
you know you'd say diff of these two
notebook objects
maybe there's even a menu-based UI for
doing that I'm not sure
and the viewer would initially show you
kind of a window onto a newly created
kind of diff notebook
but presumably you could pop it out so
that you go to the left notebook the
right notebook with markup on it
and of course if you got that raw diff
object
and
in a place where those notebooks were no
longer accessible your toast
yeah
um
we'll have to wrap up here in a moment
but yeah I actually I was I I did want
to kind of bring us to a conclusion with
a few questions about next steps so but
I didn't want to interrupt any yeah I
think I think we've got the design
Direction here which I think is really
good and I mean there's a lot of detail
to work through here okay since we have
the bioinformatics folk here
um
I want to ask the question about NY uh
alignment
and just a reminder for me multiple
sequence alignment
is this phenomenon is this thing right
you have many sequences and you're
asking what their relative changes are
is that a true statement
yes
or you've got one little sequence and
you want to find it in a whole you want
to find a host of other sequences that
contain it or contain portions of it
let's let's let's talk about probably
the more common scenario
okay so so we've got
give me something really concrete we've
got the cytochrome C Gene of a gazillion
animals or something
and we are trying to ask a question how
do all these differ or what what is what
is the question we're asking no it's a
typical question is here's a
DNA sequence a small one they are in
this five million sequences today occur
and the other ones are typically much
longer
okay so so I mean it's it's
what's the real case of this it's like
saying
I see I see I see I see okay so that
case would be
um of all the proteins in the protein
Data Bank
where does this particular little run of
a base you know of amino acids occur
so that I can see whether those things
twist up into weird little left hooks or
something so it's a little bit
simplified in reality you allow for a
lot of things to be included and silver
into count them but yes what do you mean
included like you mean it's only an
approximate call it it's not it's not
Chop yeah
it's not what yeah it's not it's not one
to one
if it is not a literal match
right but so that's using things like
blast and so on to to estimate whether
it's you know to get a distance metric
yeah okay so what we're asking this is
probably going to be relevant to our Dev
stuff you know edit distance is the most
basic kind of
you know change distance so to speak
right so I mean we're because you know
diffing is ultimately sort of a
heuristic thing because it's a question
of how long you know you you could say
every character is different or you
could say this group has an indel or
whatever
am I right
so
the question of what
you know when do you decide it's an
insertion deletion when do you decide
it's a reversal of characters or
something
versus
and
and when do you decide that these
sequences are close enough that you can
consider them identical even though one
has an A and one has a b in it
is that right
so in the diffing that we're imagining
here
in the end there is a way to get
precisely from one sequence to another
there are no oh there's an A in that one
a b in that I mean we we could represent
that by saying well it's an A and one
and a B in the other and it turns out we
don't care about that particular element
of the death
not making sense to people
as opposed to just saying and I don't
know how it's represent it in multiple
sequence alignment just saying we don't
care if it's a c or a g there
in fact I guess the way that's
represented is that there are in
standard you know bioinformatics Land
There are all these different codes that
go beyond Just A and C and G and T like
an N means we just don't know what what
uh you know what base pair it is there
is that right so we're we're I think
this covers many but not quite all of
the cases okay
but
but okay but so when
the question that's come up here is if
we have five files and we want to look
at their relative differences
what would be the bioinformatics way of
thinking about that process and what
would be the structure that comes out
because I mean
you know maybe it's just like our
sequence alignment function which can
only work with two sequences can't it
yes right I mean more
what's that think of like the maximum
common substructure but that's a very a
hard problem on even on simple like
chemical graphs but on expressions and
be
a very difficult
no I understand but let's just take
lists I mean we could just imagine if
the lists are the same but we have five
different lists and there's this one
spot where they all differ by in
different ways
but we could imagine doing that with the
same data structure that we're returning
for sequence alignment we could imagine
dealing with more than two strings I
believe
that makes sense
but it's important that the structure
that Lou has developed with changes and
things like that I don't think that will
work with more than two
Lou might want to comment uh it already
works for three
I mean it's just it if you I mean we can
talk about the details if you want but
it's it's extensible to arbitrary
numbers
okay okay it's not obvious to me how but
but um okay well so clearly the sequence
alignment function is extensible the way
it works it's clearly extensible you
just have runs of common sequences and
then you have the you know areas where
somebody differed and so they've all got
to be listed explicitly right and the
changes object has the same information
except with indexes along for the ride
exactly the same all right fine
fine well
okay uh I think there were some comments
on our live stream here which I had no
chance to look at
uh
it's a comment from LC about making uh
graph and tree like diff objects and
that's
an interesting question
well I don't know I mean that's a
you know this question about
representing but this is a sort of
higher level thing representing a cold
collection of diffs as a tree so to
speak but I think that's a higher level
thing
um
uh let's see
Bowie is commenting
oh those are about earlier things about
pointers and references
all right I think we're making really
good progress this is great
functionality so I wish we'd had this
decades ago yeah so so very quick next
steps uh
how
what should we do before you see this
again
think through the design as we've
discussed it try and get some graphic
design around the um what the diff
viewer looks like
uh I think those are all good places to
start okay I mean some of these things
like the granularity stuff I think we
had come to a reasonable point there
I think yeah I think we've got a path
here okay so I mean it it'll be a little
while to process those things at which
point you know will fall out of context
uh that's that's understandable I think
it's okay I think we've got far enough
that we can you know
we've got far enough that I don't think
we need to maintain context here okay
um and at some point uh before we meet
again we might we might have something
that that we would be comfortable
throwing onto the Pac-Man repository do
you have any objections to that no
okay I mean I would slightly prefer to
see it again before it goes there
because I think if they're you know
people say oh wow this is wonderful and
start using it and then we're like oh
but there's this silly thing that we
have to change then everybody's got
Pitch folks we will certainly advise
right on the front page the experimental
nature of of the packlet I mean I I
guess I you know I would have a slight
preference if you've packaged it up well
enough to put in the packet repository I
claim it's you know good enough for
another meeting but I don't violently
object if you for whatever reason want
to put it in a packed repository first
okay
all right good stuff it does make it
easier for everyone to try things
you deploy it not in the Public Public
repository but just whatever put it
there doesn't matter it's fine yeah I'm
not going to complain
um although you might want to put it
under a name that isn't whatever we
think the final name is going to be
okay
okay good stuff good luck thank you okay
bye